de Dervallières là donc à Nantes on
avait vu dans les actualités que ça
avait pas mal chauffé en ce moment du
coup on a vu qui était un lac aussi au
milieu on s'est dit bah Go pêcher
c'est dans ce quartier que l'agression a
eu lieu
enfin chercher des spots à proximité du
coup on a changé de lac l'autre était
vide et celui-là il est un petit peu
plus haut mais bon on reste à côté de la
cité quand même on va faire le côté
là-bas aussi
c'est que ça commence très bien mon
petit
on le voyait pas du tout hein
allez hop
premier vélo de la journée
non je pense qu'il est peut-être gonflé
encore ouais
il est clairement utilisable
oh il y a une pièce en même temps
regarde pas que le vélo
ça c'est un centime
[Musique]
franchement ça se fait un qui se mette
là haut là il balance une arme
c'est un panneau
et ce couteau très moche
très très moche
coup dur le pied mouillé là-dedans
tu vas avoir des champignons et pas de
ce qu'on mange avec de la crème fraîche
laissez un pouce bleu si vous voulez que
Quentin il est des champignons sur ses
orteils
[Applaudissements]
c'est un critérium SFR
bon faut vraiment qu'on fasse gaffe à la
qualité de l'eau et que rassan ne
boivent pas dedans qui a un héron qui a
pris cher là il pue pas trop bizarrement
mais bon
donc là j'ai attrapé quelque chose à au
moins
500 mètres je dirais c'est plutôt bon
signe il y a un poids correct
oui bien sûr bien sûr et oui
une petite carabine on a déjà fait des
comme ça c'est du classique
je l'ai senti là je t'ai dit à distance
comme ça je t'ai de là-haut fallait au
moins faire une
comme ça cabine de jardin il y a une
balle dedans ah merde
on va laisser comme ça on laisse ouvrir
bah du coup elle est chargée et armée
elle est chargée
merci
commence bien il y a pas mal de
reportages où on les voit ces trucs il
est cache un peu dans les cages
d'escalier là au cas où c'est voilà
c'est pas bien méchant mais ça peut être
l'étal de près ça suffit ouais ça suffit
puis c'est surtout pour impressionner et
là on l'a vu elle était chargée donc
ils l'ont pas acheté pour rien il y a eu
un truc il devait s'en servir et ils
s'en sont pas servi pourquoi ou alors
ils s'en sont servis puis ils l'ont
recharger
à l'intérieur c'est peut-être pas
forcément une arme de meurtre on sait
pas bon en tout cas on va continuer
ce que je voulais gros j'aurais été
tellement déçu Nantes sans arme ah j'ai
quelque chose encore
oh oh le coupe-boulon c'est bon ça aussi
parce que là il est vieux
ça pareil ma tasse de cité le classique
c'est de la qualité mais là il est mort
elles sont là
c'est gros hein
si vous avez une idée en commentaire
quand tu as trouvé la carabine il y
avait une femme en haut là on avait rien
à [ __ ] est totalement rien à [ __ ]
là on s'est posté depuis le belvédère
depuis lequel la carabine a sûrement été
lancée vous voyez il y a de quoi faire
des gros lancers parce qu'on est bien
surélevé Flac donc Quentin a une
technique et une idée lumineuse de
ressortir le petit aimant avec la petite
corde donc ça va permettre de jeter plus
loin ouais bon quand il dit le petit
aimant c'est quand même les menteurs
donc de chez Maison de la détection même
si c'est petit c'est du très costaud
voilà c'est le terror c'est combien de
kilomètres
pour débuter la pêche à l'aimant donc
voilà bah d'ailleurs si vous si vous
voulez vous équiper n'hésitez pas le
code promo pêcheur de trésor vous offre
moins 5% sur toute la boutique tu vas
nous faire un lancer allez on va voir
attention
le sandwich du monsieur SDF qui dort ici
mais non rasta tu ne pourras pas y aller
pour ajouter une arme
j'en ai marre il va avoir un carnet avec
écrit Baptiste et tous les trucs là
on va les appeler bon c'est une petite
carabine mais bon c'est catégorisé on va
pas ramener ça ça aucune valeur fin de
rester ça aucune valeur de restauration
et elle peut être impliquée dans quelque
chose de pas correct
bonjour
vous venez de si loin pour pêcher à
l'aimant en fait du coup on traverse
l'Europe on a jusqu'à Amsterdam
Bruxelles
vous êtes d'où de Béziers
Atlantis
bah écoutez bon courage merci bonne
journée
effectivement ça existe énormément
c'est un jean un sac plastique
regarde
comme elle est grosse
un petit peu plus loin un peu plus à
gauche
donc là j'ai quelque chose qui était
bien dans la vase
ouais
j'ai perdu on va essayer hop j'ai
peut-être un bout oh c'est bon signe ça
d'accord
encore d'été c'est un panneau et des
clés
des trucs là
ah j'ai encore un truc non
déjà un objet intéressant hors de l'eau
catalytique pas mal un peu la mangrove
je crois que j'ai quelque chose direct
ouais peut-être que c'est du bois
ne vendons pas la le bœuf avant de la
voir manger
mais peut-être que c'est du bois mais
peut-être que c'est pas du bois ça
réagit un peu comme du bois tout de même
ah non c'est un antivol
super super
il y a très peu de choses
comme ça
pas mal donc là j'ai eu quelque chose
tout au bout
je suis pas sûr c'est une branche c'est
peut-être un vélo
ah non une barrière encore du mobilier
urbain
bon on a fait le panneau la barrière la
borne et ce qui nous manque
de vélo c'est un
donc là j'ai autre chose au même endroit
que la barrière
ça a l'air plus lourd peut-être un peu
besoin d'aide
je m'en doutais un peu ouais
à mon avis tu vois ça a déjà été pêché
mais comme j'ai tiré vraiment loin après
tu vois ça devait trouver il y a 20 ans
ensemble technique
OK
il est pas carré
c'est un beau
[Musique]
on est en plein Nantes dans un tout
petit ruisseau
c'est déjà cool voilà j'ai quelque chose
oh oui pas mal une vieille bêche
ouais ça c'était de la qualité je vous
le dis
tu pourras la restaurer Baptiste si tu
veux
sympa les outils
de poubelles
ah bah oui c'est ça qu'on avait pas
encore fait du mobilier urbain
d'accord
c'est original
j'ai cru que c'était R2D2 au début mais
non encore quelque chose
que serait pas encore un outil ça
ouais il me semble ouais j'ai fait une
nouvelle poubelle je vais rajouter son
antenne
en plus je l'ai eu grâce à l'hameçon
[Applaudissements]
pour le soutien
ça fait plaisir